Jesus is obviously Superior to Muhammad
in every relevant way unless your moral
compass was built by a demon with a
severe head injury that's not in dispute
what's interesting is that Jesus is
superior to Muhammad massively Superior
to Muhammad even in the Quran and Allah
never explains why let's go through a
few passages of the Quran to see how
Jesus is greater than Muhammad and then
we'll try to figure out why Jesus is
greater than Muhammad even in the Quran
surfor verse
171 oh people of the book do not
exaggerate in your religion nor utter
anything concerning God save the truth
verily the Messiah Jesus Son of Mary was
only a messenger of God and his word
which he committed to Mary and a spirit
from him so believe in God and His
Messengers and say not three refrain it
is better for you God is only one God
glory be to him that he should have a
child unto him belongs whatsoever is in
the heavens and whatsoever is on the
earth and God suffices as a
guardian this verse is actually a very
good summary of what the Quran teaches
about Jesus because it's trying to to
deny Jesus deity while simultaneously
portraying Jesus as completely different
from Muhammad or anyone else so Jesus
was only a messenger of God and yet he's
unique in three ways in this one verse
Jesus is the Messiah what's the Messiah
the Quran never explains so you'll have
to go to Jews and Christians to find out
Jesus is the word of of God Allah's word
is something that he
speaks and Jesus is a spirit from God
Allah's spirit is something he breathes
out as we read in passages like Surah
38: 71 to 72 remember when thy lord said
unto the Angels behold I am creating a
human being from clay when I have
proportioned him and breathed into him
of my Spirit Fall Down before him
prostrating Allah breathes his Spirit
into something to give it life but Jesus
is a spirit from Allah the Quran uses
the phrase Spirit from Allah again in
Surah
58:22 you shall not find a people who
believe in God and the last day loving
those who oppose God and His messenger
even if they be their father fathers
their sons their brothers or their tribe
God has inscribed faith upon their
hearts and strengthen them with a spirit
from him who does Allah strengthen with
a spirit from him he strengthens
Believers but if this Spirit strengthens
Believers wherever they may be he's
starting to sound
omnipresent and omnipresence is a Divine
attribute why would a spirit from Allah
have a Divine
attribute so ordinarily when Allah
creates something he simply says be and
it comes into existence but Jesus
somehow originates from within Allah
he's Allah's word spoken by Allah and a
spirit breathed out by Allah Allah
strengthens Believers with a spirit from
him but Jesus is a spirit from him why
is Jesus a spirit from Allah why is
Jesus Allah's word why is Jesus the
Messiah why is Jesus different and how
did the word of Allah and a spirit from
Allah become a human being sorah 19
starting at verse 16 and remember Mary
in the book when she withdrew from her
family to an Eastern place and she
veiled herself from them then we sent
unto her our spirit and it assumed for
her the likeness of a perfect man so the
spirit of Allah appeared to Mary in the
form of a perfect man she said I seek
Refuge from thee in the compassionate if
you are reverent he said I am but a
messenger of thy Lord to bestow upon
thee a pure
boy the spirit of Allah says I am but a
messenger what did Surah 4: 171 say
about Jesus he was only a
messenger the spirit of Allah said he
was there to bestow upon Mary a pure boy
let's get some other translations for
what kind of boy Jesus was here are 10
translations a faultless son a holy son
a righteous son a pure boy a righteous
son a pure son a boy most pure a pure
boy a holy son a holy son Muhammad added
an important detail about the Purity the
Holiness the righteousness the
faultlessness of Jesus in sah alkari
3286 narrated Abu hura the prophet said
when any human being is born Satan
touches him at both sides of the body
with his two fingers ERS except Isa
Jesus the son of Mariam Mary whom Satan
tried to touch but failed so he touched
the placenta cover
instead Satan touches every child when
he's born even Muhammad but Satan
couldn't touch Jesus not surprisingly
Jesus was sinless but Muhammad wasn't in
Surah 40:55 Allah commands Muhammad to
ask forgiveness for thy sin again in
Surah 47: 19 Allah tells Muhammad to ask
forgiveness for thy sin Jesus was
faultless Muhammad was a sinner so Jesus
was morally Superior to Muhammad no
surprise there back to Mary's encounter
with the spirit of Allah she said how
shall I have a boy when no man has
touched me nor have I been unchaste he
said thus shall It Be Thy Lord says it
is easy for me and it is thus that we
might make him a sign unto Mankind and a
mercy from us and it is a matter
decreed so the spirit tells Mary that
conceiving a child even though she's a
virgin is easy for Allah how does Allah
accomplish this Surah 66:12
and Mary the daughter of Imran who
preserved her Chastity then we breathed
therein of our spirit and she confirmed
the words of her Lord and his books and
she was among the devoutly
obedient Mary preserved her Chastity
then Allah breathed therein of his
Spirit breathed into what Palmer gives
the literal translation
and Mary daughter of Imran who guarded
her private parts and we breathed
therein of our spirit and she verified
the words of her Lord and his books and
was of The
Devout Allah breathed his Spirit into
Mary's private parts now this is a bit
confusing because in 1917 Allah's Spirit
appears to Mary in the form of a perfect
man but in 6612 Allah says we breathe
therein of our spirit so who breathed
into Mary Allah or his Spirit did the
spirit of Allah breathe the spirit of
Allah into Mary or is the spirit of
Allah who appeared to Mary the spirit
that Allah breathed into Mary in other
words when Allah says he breathed his
Spirit into Mary is that referring to
him sending the spirit in the form of a
man or is the spirit of Allah part of
the we who breathed into Mary I'm asking
because this is confusing and I thought
Islamic theology was supposed to be
super
simple most Muslims today believe that
the spirit of Allah is the Angel Gabriel
but that's not what the Quran says in
fact the Quran distinguishes between
Allah's Spirit and the angels in Surah
70:4 for instance Allah says unto him
Ascend the angels and the spirit so the
spirit is distinct from the
Angels whatever the case may be Allah
breathes the spirit into Mary so that
she miraculously conceives Jesus a pure
son the Messiah the word of Allah a
spirit from
Allah why is Jesus unlike Muhammad or
the other prophets born of a
virgin the Quran says that Allah wanted
to make Jesus a sign unto
mankind but why make Jesus the sign and
not
Muhammad Allah knows best am I
right Surah 19 continues with Jesus
speaking to Mary as a baby and then
little baby Jesus speaking to Mary's
accusers this is one of the many
miracles of Jesus in the Quran Surah 5:
110 gives a summary of these
Miracles then God will say oh Jesus Son
of Mary remember my blessing upon thee
and upon thy mother when I strengthened
Thee with the holy spirit that thou
mightest speak to people in the cradle
and in maturity and when I taught Thee
the book wisdom the Torah and the gospel
and how thou wouldst create out of clay
the shape of a bird by my leave and thou
wouldst breathe into it and it would
become a bird by my leave and thou
wouldst heal the Blind and the leper by
my leave and thou wouldst bring forth
the dead by my leave and how I
restrained the children of Israel from
thee when thou did bring them clear
proofs and those who disbelieved among
them said this is not but manifest best
sorcery some of these Miracles healing
the blind and the lepers and raising the
dead are familiar to Christians speaking
to people in the cradle and creating
birds out of clay aren't but they were
at one point we know where Muhammad got
these stories they're later legends that
were circulating in Arabia during the
time of Muhammad Muhammad couldn't tell
the difference between historical
accounts and later fabrication
but think about Jesus creating out of
clay the shape of a bird and then
breathing into it and it becoming a
bird we already read about Allah
creating man out of clay and breathing
into him according to the Quran Jesus
creates life the same way Allah does
this is when our Muslim friends point
out that Jesus gave life to clay birds
by a
leave but the question is why did Allah
have Jesus create the same way Allah
creates didn't Allah know that people
were going to say oh my goodness this
boy creates things the same way God
creates them he makes things out of clay
and breathes into them surely this must
be the Son of God didn't Allah know how
people would react did Allah want to
mislead people and we can't ignore the
fact that according to the Quran
Muhammad couldn't perform Miracles Surah
29: 50 to 51 and they say why have signs
not been sent down unto him from his
Lord say oh Muhammad signs are with God
alone and I am only a clear Warner does
it not suffice them that we have sent
down unto thee the book that is recited
unto them surely in that is a mercy and
a reminder for a people who
believe no miracles for poor Muhammad
the closest he got to a miracle was
delivering the worst book I've ever
read so Jesus spent his life healing
people and telling people to believe in
God and for some reason people wanted to
kill him for it but they failed because
Allah wouldn't let Jesus enemies kill
him as we read in sah 4: 157 to 158 and
for their saying this is supposedly a
group of Jews saying this we slew the
Messiah Jesus Son of Mary the messenger
of God though they did not slay him nor
did they crucify him but it appeared so
unto them those who differ concerning
him are in doubt thereof they have no
knowledge of it but follow only
conjecture they slew him not for certain
but God raised him up unto himself and
God is mighty
wise there are some Muslims who believe
that Jesus was crucified so they
interpret this differently but the vast
majority of Muslims believe that this
passage is claiming that Jesus wasn't
killed and wasn't crucified Allah
protected Jesus even though he didn't
protect Muhammad according to the had
Muhammad died from the effects of poison
after he was poisoned by a Jewish woman
so Allah rescued Jesus but he let
Muhammad die and Jesus is going to
return to fight the Antichrist most of
the details of Jesus second coming in
Islam are found in the Hadith but
there's a passage in the Quran that
Muslims believe is about the return of
Jesus Surah 43: 57 to6 1 and when the
son of Mary is set forth as an example
Behold thy people turn away from it they
say are our Gods better or is he they do
not cite him to thee save to dispute nay
they are a contentious people he was not
but a servant whom we blessed and whom
we made an example for the children of
Israel had we willed we would have
appointed Angels Among you succeeding
one another upon the Earth
and he is indeed a portent of the hour
so doubt not concerning it and follow me
this is a straight path he Jesus is a
portent of the hour here's the
commentary in the study Quran according
to traditional Islamic belief Jesus did
not die on natural death rather God
raised him up unto himself in
traditional Islamic eschatology Jesus
return to Earth is among the signs of
the end of time the prophet is reported
to have said one of the signs of the
hour will be the appearance of Jesus the
son of Mary before the day of
Resurrection at which point it is said
that he will fight the Antichrist Al
deal eventually die and be resurrected
like other
Mortals putting all of this together
according to the Quran and some related
sources Jesus is the word of Allah
Muhammad isn't Jesus is a spirit from
Allah Muhammad isn't Jesus is the
Messiah Muhammad isn't Jesus had a
miraculous birth Muhammad didn't Jesus
was sinless Muhammad sinned like it was
a sport Jesus spoke as a baby Muhammad
didn't Jesus lived Liv the most
miraculous life in history Muhammad made
excuses for why he couldn't perform
Miracles Jesus raised the dead Muhammad
made people dead Jesus created the same
way Allah creates Muhammad couldn't
create a book worth
reading Jesus was rescued by Allah from
those who wanted to kill him Muhammad
wasn't and Jesus will return to fight
the Antichrist Muhammad will stay in his
grave
why is Jesus so shockingly unique in
Islam why is Jesus different in so many
ways from everyone else why is Jesus
Superior even to Muhammad again didn't
Allah know that by making Jesus so
incredibly unique people were going to
conclude that he's the Divine Son of God
so why did Allah do it let me guess
Allah Knows Best
the real answer here is oddly enough
found in the Quran Surah 25: 4 to 5 and
the disbelievers say this is not but a
lie that he has fabricated and another
people have helped him in it they have
indeed produced a wrongdoing and a
calumny and they say they are faes of
those of old which he has had written
down and they are recited to him mour
and
evening the Quran points out that people
during the time of Muhammad were
accusing him of having fables written
down and then passing them off as
Revelations Surah 9: 61 and among them
are those who torment the prophet and
say he is an
ear they called Muhammad an ear because
he would believe the stories of anyone
who came to visit him Muhammad heard a
lot of stories about Jesus some of them
true some of them later Legends he
didn't understand the theological
implications of those stories so he
included them in the Quran he thought he
could just add Jesus was only a
messenger to claims about Jesus being
the word of God he thought he could just
add by Allah's leave to stories about
Jesus creating the same way God creates
but it didn't work because he ended up
with a Jesus who's Superior to him in
every way that
matters how amazing is Jesus that even
when the most obvious false prophet in
history dedicates years of his life to
trying to drag Jesus down to his level
the contrast between Jesus and Muhammad
is still the contrast between light and
darkness life and death Heaven and Hell
[Music]